I'm going to talk about that until you
go like my [ __ ] right now like my [ __ ]
is trying to start the music but I'm so
technologically [ __ ] I'm Kate
Quigley I'm so pumped cuz they got my
boy here today dude I wanted to have you
on the show forever for real
also just hang out for real just want to
stare at you for real gonna be a really
boring episode of date fails because I
have Jamar neighbors here and we're just
gonna stare at each other so there's
gonna be nothing else that happens
boring for you yea if you're listening
tomorrow's gonna be taking off as close
and if you can't see the podcast you're
really missing out because this man dude
first of all you're blowing up right now
you're on the roast battle yeah Comedy
Central how's that going [ __ ]
fantastic I you know it's a dream come
true I just get to act like a clown I
felt like I'm actually just living out
my dream was just running away to join
the circus you really are so cool where
are you from I don't know much I was
like excited to have you here because I
feel like you're one of those people
that I see around all the time in comedy
and we've been like pals and we text a
little bit we flirted a little bit but I
never really got to like know you well
here it is it's like our first date by
the way are you single
yeah kinda sorta
just back this [ __ ] up yeah where are
you from I'm from Compton born and
raised bum - shut up - yg I know that
you grew up here yeah I'm from here born
and raised yeah up Compton but I moved
around like the hoods of LA you're here
from all the hoods I'm not I'm not a
gangster as [ __ ] but you can say
whatever you want I ain't a gangster ass
[ __ ]
Santa but you know what I'm saying I
grew up around easy you know you know
the mean streets they're like man you
know I'm saying I do yeah I've spent a
lot of time on the mean streets I don't
know if you can tell you're okay I'm
from Ohio I grew up in Canton what's
that like it's like is like a small
suburb kind of like growing up in like a
glendale's but not quite as nice we had
a lot of money um no I'm kidding no I
was so poor growing up my parents we
live this is the thing for where you
came all right so we lived in in a nice
area but my parents were married and my
dad made money and then my parents
divorced and my dad was like I hate my
job I quit and he just up and quit his
job so we pretty much it was my mom and
three kids living in like a great area
but with no money so everyone started
giving us like I do where like I was so
embarrassed things I was always running
like people's old clothes that were like
three years old to school and stuff I
was really like The Biggest Loser
yeah yeah not at all in high school no
it's crazy that lately I don't know I
feel like rarely like that's the very
popular kid become the it's true right
yeah I know a few of the popular kids
would be a become who did get like
successful and so but like it's I think
it's rare I think so too because I think
well for one the popular kids are
usually like the hot kids right and so
they don't have to do
velop personality cuz they're just hot
mm-hmm I was ugly as [ __ ]
what's so ugly I wish I had photos and
we could show him on here I was the
ugliest like from pretty much from like
a - like 21 yeah I wasn't 21 but I was
just kind of like okay yeah you were
kind of coming into yourself a little
bit yeah I was hideous though for like
years
I had like crooked teeth huge eyebrows
like I'd look like a dude
really yeah man date that did not well
not like I wasn't like the man yeah I
was kind of like the I was kind of like
that nigga's hilarious let's do it
always funny yeah let's go over here
this crazy maybe talk about are you
getting in trouble a lot like where you
look class clown guys yeah yeah I was
like bad really I've made like teachers
like quitting [ __ ] I'm sure I was like
the worst like student like smart like I
finished all my work but then it's like
but then it's like alright so now what
now I'm bored
you made teachers quit yeah yeah I
remember making a Mis Weinstock quit my
art teacher
do you know it was because of you cuz
cuz I would talk [ __ ] like all the
[ __ ] time or whatever and then I I
would just drive her crazy she'd be
think I can't handle this
I had one teacher that I love to
antagonize and I was in high school it
was my French teacher yeah and I don't
know what it was about her she was this
like kind of [ __ ] old lady and there's
just something about her that rubbed me
the wrong way and in that class
somewhere I would an antagonize her the
more I would make all the kids laugh
that's really how I like fell in love
with making people laugh so I would like
learn like awful phrases in French
relations where like say things like you
know your your dad's a [ __ ] or whatever
but in French how do you say that
and I was so bad at French that would
come in and I would [ __ ] up everything
the whole class and then I'd be like I
did practice this one thing though I did
learn how to say your dad's a [ __ ] and
then I'd stay and then she'd get so
angry and she'd yell your favorite class
be like her face turned so red and then
she'd always sent me out of the class
and I'd have to go to the principal's
office and I think my principal deep
down though just like thought it was
hilarious
what would she yeah don't you think the
principal half the time if I was a
principal half the time I just feel like
this [ __ ] is awesome so funny I okay so
like I remember in like 12th grade um
like 12th grade this teacher name name
is Manuel the meanest like the meanest
uh Dean ever and they had a they had a
talent show coming up and she was like I
went to the office whatever and I was
sitting there and she was like you she
was at like tell me a joke so funny tell
me a damn joke
and I was at the like I came in so I was
like um so I was like so I'm from like a
gang-related like neighborhood or
whatever sounds like yeah man so um so
um this dude was like hey man um I'm
from I'm from the 60s and I was like
then I was like [ __ ] the 60s and the 60s
is a gang he was like I'm from the 60s
and I was like [ __ ] the sixties he was
like [ __ ] what he was like why you say
that and I was like oh because my mom
was born in the 60s and this and this
and that and then she just laughed she
thought it was the funniest [ __ ] ever
cuz like that I don't know but it was
just dope to make that that mean [ __ ]
laugh and [ __ ] like that but I never did
do it you didn't you were never in a
town show
ai ai ai I auditioned but I never did
actually do this show oh you just you
yeah you bailed yeah why what were you
doing chasing [ __ ] no acting oh so
funny in high school I wasn't even like
obviously like a [ __ ] chaser really no
no mostly I was like a late bloomer what
were you doing in high school it's
[ __ ] on No
there's being kind of silly flags with
me a stupid oh my god I like guys that
don't start getting into girls so later
than Hannah yeah like I didn't lose my
virginity I was like 20 really yeah
so wait did you go to college mm-hmm so
no so it was in college then but but
even but even in college I wasn't
getting like I wasn't even getting like
Matt [ __ ] I kind of just recently
started getting getting a lot of it
wait is that because the Rose battle no
no no it's it's your body dude this guy
you're banging on my face your face is
hot body is [ __ ] like it's and you
know what I love is that I [ __ ] love
this about you that you will post photos
of you naked in your underwear onstage
with no shirt on and I look at it and I
go [ __ ] yeah finally like a hot dude
that's doing this [ __ ] Kate does it why
I came thank you no but everybody but
you know what's funny is that's why I
love when you do it because so many
people have given me [ __ ] about it and
I'm just like you know who gives a [ __ ]
like it's just every once a while and
none of this [ __ ] matters anyway things
matter how are you you're so were you
always in shape like this uh no I mean
kind of like athletic play sports yeah
but uh I I play football for a little
bit but I played baseball and everything
but I was always just like my cousin's
used to have like weights and [ __ ] in
the house and I will [ __ ] around and I
think you're gonna say steroids my
cousin's used to have steroids in the
house I would [ __ ] up I'm like it's
working you look amazing
yeah yeah so yeah I was always just kind
of in might just Atlantic light weight
training a lotta [ __ ] and then our
recently start box and I heard I heard
um from a friend who was on the last
episode Jen Sturge er she goes you gotta
ask Gemara about this first time I ever
met him he showed me a picture of his
dick I thought it would kind of stand
out I know
I mean I've shown so many people my big
but I remembered showing Jim Sturgess or
Mundy
like okay can you just explain to me how
it happens that you meet someone and
somehow end up showing them a dick photo
and by the way she said it lovingly so
it must be a fantastic dick Manas a dope
dick is it it's a dope look would you
think about that I'm surprised that you
haven't tweeted a photo of your dick
before to be honest with you you know so
funny is that like even like what they
Donna crazy this is like there's still
like a professional type you know say
like ah yeah well I I used to I used to
send them out and [ __ ] like that but
then I got an odor and I got smarter and
I was like no Niki you can't just be
sitting here everywhere yeah you should
try not to all but I'll show you all my
okay yeah yeah if you could get that out
real quick I see I don't keep nudes
either because I feel like it's tacky to
recycle them so when when I start seeing
somebody new I take new ones I think
it's just I do I'm not gonna lie I have
like one or two really good ones on hand
just in case of like I need a really big
apology you know I really [ __ ] up and I
got it like send out like the trump card
but that's it yeah yeah but uh that's
funny that you've just shown it randomly
yeah I usually show that [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time I used to be like hey I
want to see a picture of my niece so how
did you get into stand-up I don't even
know I mean I've always wanted to do
this and I was a kid um yeah I was
younger and when my football dreams
failed like when I was like 11 I was
like I was like you know what yeah
because I used to play a lot of flag
football then when I started playing Pop
Warner were yet to tackle people and I
was like oh I'm not you know like I
don't wanna get hurt they these these
these [ __ ] with nothing want it too
bad that's hilarious
I still play do you ever play for fun oh
absolutely yeah me too I love playing
football we should get a lead going
actually yeah what's up with that
probably at least some it looks like a
flag football yeah yeah well girls can
tackle yeah okay girls can tackle guys
can okay cool I like that's really what
part of the fun of playing is just
getting to tackle guys I like to take
all my aggression yeah on man out on
guys in sports really playing there you
play tennis I do I play volleyball
actually it's funny you said you box cuz
I used to kick box with Ahmed Ahmed like
I used to go to the beach and we would
like train and kick box and stuff I love
that show yeah yeah yeah I kind of want
to join a boxing gym yeah I got a
fortune boxing gym oh yeah Pacquiao shot
before some boxing gym so alright so you
at 11 you were like I'm not gonna play
football I'm gonna do stand-up it was
like well I do stand-up but then I was
really good at football too and I was a
kid and I was like let's see how this
works out and then at that time like
when I just quit and I was like you know
yeah I'll just be a football player in
something that's how I'll play a
football player well you're pretty close
I mean I feel like you're you're pretty
much doing that on the roasts battle you
get very athletic yeah hell yes do
pedantic all right so now suddenly
you're swimming in [ __ ] apparently no
no no no no no no but it no have you
what's the longest relationship you've
ever had are you counting days it was
like four and a half five years oh wow
really mm-hmm
that's serious mm-hmm I like that you
just had to count it out though yeah
yeah I was like telling it I waste my
time oh it was from 18 through 23 it was
an off-and-on thing 18 to 23 yeah how do
you know I'm 30
oh damn you look good yeah have five
years I still stalk her on Instagram you
do she doesn't know you still stalk her
on Instagram yeah cuz she got she got
like marry and [ __ ] and I'm like what is
she working out
why did that end we just kind of grew
apart
yeah cuz you were so young yeah and then
since then any girlfriends yeah I don't
think you out a girlfriend since I've
known you not like serious maybe you
have I've had like I've had a girlfriend
or two you have but not like nothing
that intense light light as intense as
that five-year thing how do you meet
girls you go on dating apps like I've
tried tinder and souls wipe well it's
all white it's black tinder what it's
satellite do you like downloading right
now do you kill it on tinder well I I
use tinder every listen let me be honest
with you every girl that's not ugly
kills it onto you swipe on tinder it's
just match match match match that's all
you get are matches so I mean yeah but I
don't often actually go out with these
guys you know what I remember going on a
tinder date and spinning like it's been
like three hundred dollars what would it
mean get no [ __ ] where'd you go okay so
first we started off at UH at sounds
comedy hole oh wow great start for those
of you who don't know Sal's comedy hole
is exactly like it sounds a [ __ ] hole
you can catch me there tomorrow day just
kidding salads comedy Hall is is a
comedy club kind of in the back of a
coffee shop right it's a rental food is
delicious food is amazing so he took her
there for dinner you had a show it was
in the morning I was like out there
knows 12 okay it was really a chick also
swipe and I was like I'll say tell me
something I'll get back to this yeah
yeah please and I was like I was like
tell me I was like she was like tell me
something about yourself or whatever and
I was like all right or she'll they tell
me a secret or something I was like all
right
what the [ __ ] I told her but I was like
you tell me something she was like all
right I've had two abortions in the last
year my name is Aisha
why the [ __ ] would you I guess she's
telling you that so that you don't have
to worry that she's gonna have your baby
if you knock her up like who says that
this is like I had two abortions in the
last god damn good lord
aah what he twins and then when you
[ __ ] her how was it the baby out that
[ __ ] okay so back to your tinder date
so you're at Sal's comedy hall having
lunch so I'm at sounds comedy hello and
I'm having lunch whatever in the dates
good you know I was like oh man um I've
never I've never tricked off on a girl
before
just let me see how let me see how that
is wait I'm sorry
tricked off for the white people what
the [ __ ] does that is tricked tricked
off when the girls like I've never spent
like that like that like I gotta kind of
it was kind of my icon it was an
experiment for me wanted to try it yeah
that's what happens $300 on a girl
versus how much do you typically spend
on a date what's a typical date for you
like drinks okay but we'll say typically
you don't you don't spend a lot anyway
so I was like all right I was like let
me see him I was like hey this date is
going great you want to go to you want
to do something else she's like yeah
[ __ ] it I'm free all day I really liked
you because I'm usually like yeah I have
one hour to give you of my day and then
I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here that's
it yeah it is all right so we go to sky
Zone is that like a skydiving thing no
it's a trampoline park Oh fine where's
that in the valley nice
that's a great move for a dude to take a
check there yeah it was hella fun I'm
sure it was was she wearing just like
some um bandana salsa all right at that
I was like so what you want to do now
and then she was like she was like I
don't know I was like you want to go to
the beach and then she was like and I
was like oh let's go to Santa Monica
Pier soon as I said I'm Monica Pier and
[ __ ] right alright so this is when I
knew that I wasn't about to this [ __ ]
was not about to happen so the Santa
Monica Pier Europe in there of course
yeah you know the the ferris wheel
yep so he's on the ferris wheel right
was all the way at the top
O'Shea and I tried to like yeah move and
[ __ ] and I talked to like you know
finger banger that sounds so great to me
to be honest that's a great I wish I had
a [ __ ] so I get fit so I tried to move
so I tried to move in and [ __ ] and then
she moved out of the way no admissions
just started snapping or whatever right
it is and she snapped everything but
then when she got to me she kinda like
stopped it or whatever
Oh shame I was like oh [ __ ] that means
she's got some other situation or
something when I she didn't want you in
there yeah sudden I was like I was like
[ __ ] I don't even think I'm a alright so
after that we went to the to Joe's Crab
Shack or - boy no not Joe's perhaps like
the boiling crab whatever the crawfish
yeah the place on the pier 99 and I it's
like in my Koreatown somewhere it was
like holy [ __ ] wait for people that
don't live in our way
you went from Sal's comedy hall to the
valley which is in traffic like an hour
and a half [ __ ] drive to Santa Monica
Pier which in traffic is another hour
now to Koreatown which in traffic is
another out you've done like 400 miles
yeah I started driving for uber like
after that yes I went there whatever
nearly eight and [ __ ] and there so I
just drop her off
and nothing what and then and then and
then I saw her and then I saw her I see
her I don't know but that [ __ ] is still
on tinder I hit her from tinder and
again and as she didn't respond and I
was at the light okay so that's what
happens trick off on a chick oh wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute did
you kiss no nothing not even a kiss
goodnight oh let me ask you this if she
had just kissed you goodnight then would
you have life feeling like I next time
imma [ __ ] yeah
or would you have still been like I was
still been pissed off if she if
something happened like on the ferris
wheel or some [ __ ] like I am surprised
after the ferris wheel you still took
her all the way to Korea town for dinner
cuz I was still like cuz I was still I I
was well for me it was an experiment
right like it was like if I spend $300
on or if I spend this amount of money on
a girl will you do you get the [ __ ] at
the it was like no I have to say it's
more it's cool that that happened though
because the truth is guys think they
have to spend a lot of money on dates to
get laid it has nothing to do with how
much money you spend I mean here if a
guy doesn't pay for me though like I
went out on a date with a guy we were
kind of friends okay like we'd hung out
three or four times as like friends but
I could tell something might happen and
then one night we started like flirty
texting right like he's sexting a little
bit and then I was like oh next time we
hang out we'll probably end up hooking
up the next time we went out he starts
making out with me and then the bill
comes and he doesn't pay so that in my
mind I was a little confused because I
was like wait well kind of making out
but we had been friends before and we'd
always split checks cuz we'd always just
hung out as friends but now once I kiss
a guy in my mind you just turned into
like the man on this like whatever this
is and you gotta pay so it kept me from
hooking up with them cuz in my head I
was like oh I'm so in the friend zone
even though we just made out
so confused that's why would you not why
would you not pay for dinner I don't
understand that I mean I guess I guess
he was trying to be like yo we're
friends just cuz this just happened
doesn't mean you're good this is gonna
be dead I think guys sometimes do it to
like delineate cuz guy to you ya think
I'm not saying he wouldn't have [ __ ] me
I'm saying I'm saying sometimes I think
that guys want to draw a line like hey
this is just gonna be dick if you want
it it's not going to be dating so I'm
not paying or whatever guys do this to
me all the time Jamar I'm I am like
either a side chick all the time or like
just a girl guys want a bang but not
really date for whatever reason so I get
this off in that like I'll hook up with
a guy but they'll be really careful to
like make it clear through their actions
that that's all it is but it's probably
my fault what do you what do you want
well now I just I just finally like came
out I just finally came out on the show
and said that I really do want to like
actually date someone for real I don't
want to necessarily like move in get
married like I'm not going to spring a
time with some but I want something more
than just like to go [ __ ] somebody yeah
winter's coming
it is cuffing season it is cuffing
season well that's the thing I don't
cuddle are you big cuddler cuz I don't
cuddle unless I really [ __ ] like
somebody I can I do like I like that I
like that [ __ ] but then but what this is
what it is I'll cuddle and [ __ ] but if I
fall asleep it's you over there and I'm
over here I think that's how everybody
is once you're asleep it's like get off
he's a cuddler we're all small and I
always say that girls fall in love with
the cuddling not like the sax or
anything anything else I feel like I
didn't Iike hose you afterwards you're
doing it's for me it's if I can sleep
because I have trouble sleeping
somewhere that I'm not like if I'm not
at home
mm-hmm so if I let's say we hook up and
I try to stay over mm-hmm 90% of the
time I'm kind of like sleeping with one
eye open type thing like I never really
get sleep at a dude's place which is why
I don't stay over if I stay and I sleep
really sleep mm-hmm that means I like
you so much that my brain let me like
shut down and go to sleep
Wow so I know if I fall asleep with a
guy I'm like oh [ __ ] this one I really
like this one mm-hmm
that's why I never chance a chance at
night overstay oh yeah yeah it's good
which is good
get out that's so funny that I'm on
soulswipe now do you have any advice for
me on soulswipe for things that I can
list in my bio to win you can just put
I'm white okay so you spent 300 bucks on
the chicken you found out well that's
good see it's all about actions actually
but I kind of already III kind of always
kind of knew that my and always thought
that guys who spent who spent the gang
of money I mean it's also it's also how
it's also like how do you spend it on on
the chick though like if I don't know no
you're right you're totally right yeah
like I feel like it's kind of how you
spend it well like here's a great
example I went out with a guy one time
and all we did was go out for drinks you
know there's nothing big so what is that
fifty bucks or you know three drinks in
LA or whatever fifty bucks something
like that it's not a ton of money but
then on the way home we stopped it like
a CVS or something he just wanted to he
wanted to grab some stuff so we stopped
it like a Walgreens and we were walking
through and I picked up a pillow pet
like the dumbest [ __ ] thing that I'll
light up pillow pet I was like oh my god
this I was like these things are so cute
my nephew has when I was like look at
what it does they turned it on it like
flashlights on the ceiling she was like
cool get it and I was like no no I don't
need to spend money on that he's like no
I'm buy it for you this guy bought it at
ten bucks I thought of that guy every
time I looked at that [ __ ] pillow
pack forever I I would do something like
that yeah I like I like I like I think
that that's that's that's kind of sweet
it's so sweet and that's it it's like
it's not expensive but it was just
because like in that moment
she's like yeah I'm gonna get this for
you a lot a lot of chicks I found out to
be just going out for [ __ ] just for
the meals oh my god yeah I know a lot of
girls like I have girlfriends who are
broke and they're like I just I go on a
date everyday because I'm hungry
they don't give up no I never do that
but I kind of have a rule about it like
if a guy buys me a drink
I will sit with him at the bar and have
that drink
and I won't walk away til that drink is
gone like I feel guilty if a guy offers
to buy you a drink you buy it you know
he buys it and then you're like cool
piece and you walk off but I won't let
him buy me a second drink if I'm not
into it
if I wouldn't go out with him that's it
yeah do you buy stranger's drinks at
bars no that's good I have I have a hat
before because I had never done it
before
oh really yeah so you just like to
expand that kind of person where I'm
just like let me see what this does
like are you trying to be the most
effective way of getting a girl to
respond then if you just want to get
some if I was one I guess I know one
thing that you do that cracks me up by
the way and this is what I really
started to really like when you go on
like Twitter and he'll just tweet [ __ ]
like who wants to come over with that
[ __ ] horn yeah no no no no no no even
even even with all even with all the
vagina I'm no no I don't know I never
really works why are you suddenly so
popular with the ladies I can tell
something's going on you know what it is
but a lot a lot of them like uh I don't
know cuz I probably think that like they
probably think that I'm like I'm like
somebody
oh it's cuz your Twitter verify check
mark people like oh but it's not yeah
but I don't get like but I don't get
like a gang of girls but like but like
but then like the past five years though
but this year has been very slow if you
guys could see his face you didn't lit
up like a [ __ ] Christmas tree I'm
trying to be political with these
answers episode I talked about how I
broke my 30-day challenge and I was
trying to go 30 days without sex and I
made it to day six and then I [ __ ]
somebody that I really shouldn't have
are you a nympho kind of 30s are so
[ __ ] horny do you remember how horny
you are when you're like 17 yes that's
what it's like when you're like my it's
crazy Jamar and I don't [ __ ] a lot of
guys I really don't I mean on this
podcast it sounds like I do I really owe
certain guys a lot yes yeah yes
that's I think that's more me it is yeah
not guys Paul Paul's not yeah I think
that's what it is like it's like all
certain girls whatever but I mean he's
women - catching on to me man it's
slowing that what do you mean that
catching on do they realize you're
hitting it with a bunch of chicks you
mean you know what happens to me is like
it's like they it's like I I could I
could be not [ __ ] or whatever and
Intel are all right now I'm doing
anything tonight and they think that I'm
going out to go [ __ ] another chick and
then a lot of times what happens to me
is that a lot of girls think that I'm
[ __ ] everybody so they don't [ __ ] me
yeah yeah so that [ __ ] happens - well
the way I'm talking on this podcast I'll
[ __ ] you would think here's the thing
guys sometimes can shoot themselves in
the foot by being elusive like I was
dating a guy and I think what it is is
guys want the girl to think like that
they got options and stuff so it makes
the girl want them more but the problem
is like sometimes like we can't help it
our mind goes to here if we're dating
and I'm like yo what are you doing
tonight can I come over and you're like
all I got plans if you don't say what
the plans are I just assume you have a
date I assume it's another girl I mean I
really do now okay
so so what are you tonight can I come
over
um and I'm like no Neil he must be
[ __ ] somebody else that [ __ ] know me
better than I know myself
that's a great that's a great but a lot
of times like something like when I when
I get that text I like a lot of times I
really just want to be by myself know a
hundred percent but then if I was a guy
I'm just saying you should just be like
you know what I'd love to see you
tonight but I got a super early morning
or I'd love to see you tonight but I
promised my boy but I would make a
reason even if it's not okay but if he's
but if he's just very vague what do you
like this [ __ ] somebody or my biggest
pet peeve is when guys are like maybe
can we play it by ear because when a guy
says to me play it like your third
choice or like if I can't [ __ ] somebody
else I'll hit you up that's what I think
and I think that's what every girl
thinks and I think guys know we think
that well yeah it's sometimes sometimes
it is I can always speak for myself and
like but like sometimes it is that but a
lot of times it's like I mean let me see
how I'm feeling man it's another I just
be tired yeah that's true sometimes just
don't want to be bothered
you know oh like [ __ ] when does that
happen like [ __ ] like [ __ ] is a [ __ ]
as the [ __ ] but it's like it ain't my
yesterday in my life I mean I got and
it's a lot of work yeah yeah I mean it's
like well I'm I'm kind of some work
makes you work well cuz I mean like I
expect a lot of orgasms if I'm coming oh
I'm coming over I'm not coming over for
you to like come in five minutes or 10
minutes I expect at least an hour for ya
man let me hit the blue and I get right
back to hit the blonde and get right
back to you guys nothing worse to me
than if I like drive to somebody's house
and I like and here's the thing guys
don't understand - and this is part of
the play by ear thing
I just tell you to be real with you guys
but I don't think of this [ __ ] when a
guy says can we just play it by ear okay
guys can play it by ear because if
you're gonna [ __ ] you're gonna hop in
the shower and then you're gonna [ __ ]
that's it
when a girl knows she's gonna [ __ ] you
she's gonna like shave she's gonna maybe
she's gonna put on her like extra
expensive lotion that makes her like
super soft she's gonna do her hair she
overlooked it she's gonna do all this
[ __ ] to look you and then if you decide
and not in the mood at the last minute
and then she did all that work and she's
not gonna [ __ ] you is she gonna go [ __ ]
somebody else usually if I do all that
work to get ready and then a guy blows
me off I find something to do because
I'm like I don't want to waste it I got
ready I might not [ __ ] someone else but
at least setup another guy to like hang
out yeah mm-hmm and then and then play
it by ear to say Tuesday I mean there's
some playing by yeah yo let's talk about
this has been happening to meet up
mm-hmm-hmm let's talk about women T's
and [ __ ] humans guys yeah yeah what's
up with that what do you mean so all
right
be specific no one's listening that
knows you all right I'll go [ __ ] so I go
over I go I go over I'll go over
somebody's somebody hits me up at 3:30
in the morning okay okay
and you go hey I'm uh hey I'm up and I'm
bored and say you know dudes ways they
are you up yeah I can't believe your
phone goes up at 3:30 you check it by
yeah yeah [ __ ] like Lambie oh so uh yeah
I said what you doing whatever
and I go where you live and then she
goes oh blah blah and I was like okay
that's not ly a couple minutes for me
and then I was like I was I also give me
20 minutes
can I just get a little background is
this somebody you've hung with before
hung with like hooked up at all no
nothing but but you know each other
you've met okay but I can tell that I
can tell that there's some chemistry or
something yeah
so three morning.this all right Bobo ah
so uh so she was like she was like a
sick by the way we're not gonna have sex
and I was like I was like cool I'll say
cool cool as in we'll see yeah that's
like the most famous last words a girl
can say by the way we're not gonna yeah
right yeah so I was like all right cool
so I go over there and [ __ ] and go over
it so go up there and uh her house is
dark as [ __ ] she has a roommate or
whatever in the house is dark and this
[ __ ] comes out excuse me this chick I'm
from the hood that's how it comes out or
whatever and she has like these short
shorts on and [ __ ] like the [ __ ] hard
to stop and all this [ __ ] and I was like
all right so I was like all right
whatever that's why would she sleep man
she took me to her room and in the dark
late in the [ __ ] bed and she's like
get in and I was like and um so she
started talking about like sex and [ __ ]
like that so I was like alright well
that's a sudden boom blah so I try to
make my move in [ __ ] she's like now what
no nothing no and I was like alright
well I'll say it so I tried something
else I'm Ansley now second age we're not
gonna have sex and I was like well [ __ ]
why are you letting me did you ask her
why did you why did you invite me over
here and bring me in your bed if you
weren't trying to fog knob I didn't say
that but I've figured that it's like I
don't know the only thing I can think of
the only thing I can think of is she
likes you and thought somehow she got
you over and kind
taeju but didn't [ __ ] you and then left
you with that it make you one or more
and maybe you'd hit her I mean I think
that's so weird cuz I would I would
never do that but I grow up man and just
[ __ ] no I mean it's always different for
girls it is different for girl here's
the thing I and I say this all the time
like it's easier for me to [ __ ] a guy I
don't really like then to [ __ ] a guy
like because I know me and I know if I
like him that once we hook up is the
potential for crazy because once you
catch feelings and the guy doesn't feel
it back is when the girl starts to like
go a little cuckoo so I avoid hooking up
with guys I really like so but here's
the thing I would never invite a dude
over at 3:30 in the morning not [ __ ] not
[ __ ] him ever I there's no reason I
can't think of one reason I would do
that unless it's like my gay best friend
I just want to talk are you guys good
friends cool cuz if you're friends I
mean maybe she really was bored was she
like coked out or something cuz I'm just
like maybe she's just wide awake and
bored but I still wouldn't bring you in
bed with me yeah I don't know that's
weird
I mean I can see there are guys that I
flirt with and send like photos back and
forth with and we like sext a little bit
but I maybe wouldn't hook up with them
but there's no way that that's even a
form of teasing it is it is it is it to
feel like like you're like like your
attention like yeah well here's the
thing I have a couple guy friends who I
know I'm not gonna hook up with it but
so today I'm honest about me I'm like
we're not gonna hook up I'm not into
that way but sometimes they'll bugged me
and bugged me and bugged me for photos
yeah and so I do have a few guy friends
I'm like look if I send you a photo
your friend zone because if I let you
see me naked
but in a non-sexual way before we've
hooked up then you automatically are
friendzone for life so cool with that
you can have the picture if you're not
cool with that don't ask me for a photo
ever again I do that because most guys
are like cool then I don't want it but a
few times my guy friends have been like
cool I'll be friendzone for life I don't
give a [ __ ] and I'm like
give me the photos yes so then I have a
couple guy friends that when I'm not
dating anyone and I just need a little
validation yeah sometimes I'll just be
like hey I've no one to send this to
here and it's nice cuz I'm not right
back oh you're so hot whatever it makes
me feel good make something feel good it
depends it depends you and I don't think
we could do it we have too much sexual
attention [ __ ] yeah okay so how about
this
what that was a pretty good failed
failed attempt at getting laid but can
you think of like the worst date you've
ever been on I mean you've kind of
already told to $300 once I was thinking
that $300 in no [ __ ] that's pretty bad
yeah has there been anything any other
crazy dates have you had any crazy like
fans or stalkers or anything since
you've been kind of blowing up you took
your shirt off on TV and [ __ ] I did I
sure I will take myself in a minute
I know it's all I you know like that
crazy fans no not really
oh that's good no stalkers no no no I'm
not popping like that have you ever had
a [ __ ] go crazy on you and like break
your [ __ ] or punch you or anything nuts
you can tell by the way that I'm in like
really awful relationships because I
think this is normal cuz you do all this
I've never fun I've never had a guy ever
and I've also never shown up there was
only one guy ever dated that I showed up
at his house uninvited only one time and
we were like pretty seriously dating and
that that's it I'm trying to think a
crazy girl I mean really there y'all
crazy
excuse you know we're not all crazy
we are just emotion and emotion driven
yeah yeah sensitive that's such a weird
that like like Mel
like male and female like that's such a
weird like weird logical and you're
emotional it's always like what it's
such it you know what it is I'll tell
you exactly what it is you know Jackson
McQueen right Jackson's one of my good
friends right Jackson gave me this chalk
one time and it like changed my whole
perspective on men and women and this is
it women are verbal right
super super verbal that's why we talk so
much and [ __ ] women are all about words
guys are all about action period yeah so
when you say [ __ ] to a girl like guys
know say that again Wait Wait What did
he say men are all about words men are
all about actions
mm-hmm that's why I like guys love like
a woman could never say anything to you
but if she just cooks for you and shows
up in lingerie and like gives you a
massage like guys are in love right
women we want words we want guys to
validate us with words yeah and so what
happens is guys know this so they know
what to say to keep you coming back and
women because we're verbal we hear the
words and we go oh he says he loves
that's why women they get beat by man
the guys can just go but I love you I'll
never do it again I'm sorry and women
hear the words instead of paying
attention to the actions so women always
come back for words so when a guy says
now a baby I love you there's nobody
else we're like oh he okay he means that
because he said it there could be a
bunch of chicks but you say it girls
just pay attention to words and and
Jackson was like if women paid attention
to actions the whole game would change
oh it's like if you never to a dude's
words and you only base the relationship
on what he actually does hmm the whole
power would shift hmm so that's what I'm
trying to do that's my new thing
actions that's real ignore all the words
and for guys you should listen to the
words because women when we say [ __ ] we
mean it Wow so when she says I'm not
gonna [ __ ] you she probably means it but
put them but then there's this
yeah but then there's this there's girls
who say that and in the end of [ __ ] yeah
well there are there's other factors
like alcohol happened to me the other
night
I was like I'm like I'm not [ __ ] you
and then fast forward to two drinks
later and I'm like no asses in his new
face oh man tomorrow I love you so much
more baby this is a really entertaining
those words Tamar and I are dating now
and we're in love so that's good
tomorrow
where can people find you and follow you
oh all social media at Jamar neighbor
yeah you guys should check him out he's
absolutely [ __ ] hilarious and ladies
he does post really hot photos thank you
for that I'm gonna start texting you at
3:30 in the morning and go come over bro
not [ __ ] Oh guys I'm Kate Quigley this
was Dave fails of course we'll be back
next week so tune in again bye alright
thank you
dude you're awesome